okay so we're really close now all right
and uh she's gonna just make a grab for
the gun
okay and i don't wanna plant my feet
she goes and i'm gonna move and do the
same and i get to work on my
dynamic presentation okay
so if you if you show that you're going
to go
i'm going to go okay so have a pure
instinct on what you're gonna do just
don't like
already i think it's gonna happen yeah i
don't wanna train myself to
sit here okay so just a pure simple
thing
there you go
[Music]
so you pay attention i'm moving the gun
not leaving the gun there and hoping to
stop him
he's going for the gun i move the gun
first
so we're close
wait so you don't start so far away yes
it's okay
and just like in show manuchiko you
can't wait for it to come down
please oh you can't wait for it to come
down
you have to feel the attack so the same
thing here
she's going there she goes
so if you slow down the film she moves
first
but it looks like i moved first but i
didn't move first but
i'm not waiting for you
so two things move the gun
don't keep your feet still
then find your way to the outside so
here
elbow inside just like pokeball is koki
ho
this way
and keep moving move forward
don't move backwards okay
always moving forward forward forward
forward forward
okay let's come please if you if you
look at it you're going to get
uh kokunaga and you're going to get the
front inward kazushi
okay so her intent
is what i use to get the
tilt going so if we're doing cookie hole
right i get the tilt going it's the same
thing
so her intent won't move out of the way
but you still have to have your ik
adhesion so you can actually
get that extra inch of over penetration
okay so i'm not going to go here like
this because she can just come in again
i have to be able to yield and stick
enough to get her past me okay so you're
same way as i go to the cookie hole this
hand is doing an ip adhesion on this
side
and then this one picks up for the pokey
projection
so the same thing when she goes i seek
that other hand
okay no matter where that other hand is
so let's say it's coming up to my
other part you see my body goes whoa and
then you find the
uh adhesion and the projection so i seek
the other hand and do the same technique
okay don't just focus on this hand
because that hand might punch you or
something okay so you seek the other
hand
and you do your internal aspects where
if you get on
in the same way let's say i'm going here
and this one is just
too strong then yield to the outside
just like all your other techniques so
don't be afraid to go like
too strong home then do it on the
outside okay
don't always have to be on the inside
just see contact wherever you are okay
all right so let's work on the body
reading okay so as she goes i
i'm already uh reaching for that
connection right so she goes and i'm
already reaching for it
so this time when i feel her go i'm
gonna just push
okay so i'm using the same ground vector
as she goes and
push and then
i have to hit her in her intention right
so that
i hold this back and then she's the one
that takes her feet forward and causes
the balance you get it
i'm not i'm not shoving you okay so
as she goes i just hold that and then
her i allow her legs to come underneath
okay
so that's the idea
and this just i want you to be calmer
because you're trying to go like this
you tend to root yourself
okay so you're just calm
and we're still working on drawing from
outside the square range right so i'm
here
whoa
okay all right let's try it okay so
i have my mid-foot vector he goes
and that's that's what i'm doing so do
you see how my hands stay
there okay he leaves my hand
okay so as opposed to i go then
then i'm going to start drawing i need i
want to finish this test that's what the
drill is
finish your task and then
drop okay because usually as we go for
a retention issue is you're like here
but you didn't get out of the way and
you're not really out of a retention
uh dilemma okay so this is kind of just
an abstract like
occupy myself fully of course i'm
working on the ground vector of course
i'm reading the body
but i want to do this fully and then
draw fully
close so i want you so it triggers you
okay all right let's go okay so when we
had the last drone he's going for the
gun and i moved out of the way what
happens is
that you go hurry up and get to the gun
and now you're
in here but you're still not quite out
of that dilemma do you see that
and now you're drawing and oh now i
gotta defend myself
okay defend the weapon so
you have to train yourself to be calm
enough to get yourself
out of the retention dilemma so as we're
doing the last one i come here bull
project he's going
that way you see that's what i want i
don't stop
him uh i don't disengage from him before
he's
go done going that way okay so
uh this is just a drill to
uh micro drill where he's coming in and
you're going to go like this
you see you're going to immediately run
into the problems so we're kind of
killing
multiple birds with one stone one i'm
learning how to
draw from a dynamic uh position two
i'm learning how to read the body three
i'm still ground path
right i learned a new strat a new tactic
a stock hit because oh you could throw
this to the throat right
or palm hill the face and then draw you
could do that
um but i'm really testing myself like i
do this fully
and then i come out without
the paws that's the last thing
so once once this hand goes
this is too long a pause okay but
don't slur your speech and your hair is
going like this
okay finish the move roll
and draw
read the body here he goes oh
okay i complete each one fully without
an extended pause between the two
okay